I do this character that does stand up
and I used to take him out and do things
with him and do little bits here and
there I haven't done it in like four or
five years I think did Bobby say that
character opened up for Bobby yeah but
he said I have to do it as myself too I
think in that podcast he's like okay
you're gonna come with me and open for
me in Brea but you have to do as
yourself did that ever happen it did and
I did the character uh you know who's a
character I came up with on 10 Minute
Podcast he's just this comedian right he
calls himself an open mic veteran you
know he's been doing open mics forever
and so I did it opening up for Bobby and
he's like you have to do some of it as
yourself so I just kind of did this bit
where I would do some of his jokes and
then I would take Lee Leon's silly I got
a [ __ ] wig on and I take the wig off
and I go and as myself I start
explaining it hello my name is will see
the reason that it's funny is because uh
Arnold Schwarzenegger is always he's in
these movies and he's got the thick
Austrian accent but he's like you know
my name is Ben Williams I'm a you know
I'm a cop from Colorado no you're not uh
and it doesn't make sense as the
comedian character that I'm doing
because that character doesn't do
impersonations okay carrying on and then
I put the wig back on and go back into
this dumb thing yeah and uh I don't
think it was very good but Bobby
required it in order for me to open for
him he's like you're not [ __ ] doing
it so I'm not gonna get up on stage and
not do we agreed I'll do it but
um having been up there just in you know
whatever I've done it like a dozen
[ __ ] times so we're not a bunch of
times right like nothing uh and you know
these comedians that go up every night
sometimes two times a night it's I I do
I will say I love performing in front of
people when I get the chance but it's
it's uh it's a specific thing that that
uh that I I just I just I don't know I
gotta go back to this it's like the
providing value yeah you know I think
great stand-ups are [ __ ] incredible
I'll I'll go you know when I've gone and
watch stand up you know there's your
friend you're going to see but then
there's this other person who really
speaks to you you know what I mean and
if you like one comedian a night that's
a lot because a a
a comedy club is like a [ __ ] crazy
restaurant where there's no menu and
it's like yeah what would you like
there's nothing else like that there's
like you don't go to like a like music
place what do we got here we got
Christian metal and there's some World
music and then there's a reggae thing
and it's all rammed in together
or you don't go to a restaurant
I'd love a nice steak cool first here's
a bowl of fruit loops and then then we
got you a crudite and then this is our
Sushi Tower and well what about the
steak oh the steak's coming and then
blah blah blah oh no the steak got
bumped so there's no stake but here's a
[ __ ] shitty store-bought cheesecake
yeah you know and that's what comedians
are up against when they go into a place
it's like I don't pair well with the
poached salmon you know I'm chicken
fingers I already I already am chicken
fingers so
you know these great comedians that are
able to go up on a night where poached
salmon goes up and then it's like [ __ ]
I'm you are all so spicy I got some
kicked to me for me
even going to open mics it could be a
wonderful Escape yeah I mean just
laughing laughing together with others
it can make you I don't know it just
feels really good when we've done like
you know like and I hope to do it with
doozy but like live podcasts are fun in
front of groups of people and you know
you talk to them afterwards and and take
some pictures and man they are they
forgot what the [ __ ] they got going on
yeah and a lot of them got to go back to
work the next day it's a Wednesday or
Thursday you know no it's it's it's a
lot of value I'm fortunate enough to be
busy doing my own [ __ ]